in the u.s if you're over 50 years old
you're eligible for a second coveted
booster and come fall more of us could
be rolling up our sleeves
but do we actually need a fourth jab i'm
going to break down what's known and
what's not about the science of
additional boosters and explain how a
mysterious immune system defender is
confounding experts and steering up a
debate over booster recommendations
let's start with the preliminary data
the fda looked at before authorizing a
second booster shot for people over 50
in late march 4 months after getting
their first booster in that study of
nearly 400 000 patients researchers in
israel found that a fourth dose
increased protection against severe
covet but it only looked at outcomes in
people who were slightly older 60 and
over and only up to a month after
getting that fourth jab beyond that
there isn't a lot of data you can point
to to say that um
that we need a booster in people 58 and
older
at least not
healthy people with no comorbidities you
know with healthy immune systems that's
john weary the director of the institute
for immunology at the university of
pennsylvania other researchers have also
questioned the new guidance when
regulators authorized the first round of
boosters they looked at antibody levels
to determine whether and when additional
shots were needed antibodies waned with
time and infections were expected to
rise going into the holidays which did
happen antibodies are easy to measure
quickly in hundreds or thousands of
people
that's why they're the go-to measure for
understanding how protected we are
against covet at a population level
scientists are working to fill in that
knowledge gap by tracking another immune
fighter they're called t cells and their
job is to kill infected cells which
prevents the virus from spreading
further in your body and like antibodies
they spring into action after we get
sick
specifically the coveted vaccines
trained t cells to look for the viruses
spike protein that's the structure that
helps the virus get into cells and it's
also the target for antibodies when you
get vaccinated your cells pump out
non-infectious versions of the covid19
viruses spike protein special immune
system cells called dendritic cells find
and chew up those spike proteins
then they carry those snippets back to
the lymph nodes
there the dendritic cell eaters present
their loot to a flow of t cells t cells
that recognize those snippets multiply
forming an army of millions those killer
t cells then spread throughout the body
some take up residence in the nose lungs
or other organs waiting for viral
invaders
others go home to the lymph nodes
then when you actually get infected your
trained t cells respond within a day or
two they look for signs of inflammation
a telltale sign that infected cells are
nearby
when they recognize infected cells they
kill them off
john's research shows that t cells
persist for six months after two vaccine
doses not only are they durable but
they're pretty stable that is their
numbers are not changing very much over
time preliminary data from his lab
suggests that t cells may stick around
for a year much longer than antibodies
and it's because of that longevity that
scientists are hopeful that by tracking
t cell counts it'll give them a better
understanding of if and when a booster
is needed part of the t cell and booster
mystery comes down to time as my friend
jared hopkins who covers vaccines and
the pharmaceutical industry for the wall
street journal reminded me the vaccines
have only been widely available for a
little over a year so beyond that we're
in uncharted territory the virus itself
has only been around for two years
although it sometimes feels like decades
another challenge
john and others told me that measuring t
cells requires special equipment and is
really labor intensive the technology to
measure them and how well they work at
the same scale as antibodies just
doesn't exist right now but that's why
we don't know as much about t cell
changes over time and can't use that
information to guide our decisions on
boosters that could change
john told me that companies are working
on scaling up t-cell analysis platforms
to provide that critical information so
let's go back to that first question do
we actually need a fourth jab
jared told me that we're in a really
gray area right now when it comes to
second boosters but u.s regulators uh
are eyeing a fall campaign for boosters
or the us broadly people under 50 that
is
our understanding of what we've reported
virologists and public health experts he
and i spoke to agreed they wouldn't
cause harm so that's good instead the
concern is that by getting them too
often we're not getting as much benefit
out of them so the big question is what
should the optimal spacing be the answer
will hinge on what we find out about t
cell dynamics and whether we're able to
measure that across thousands of people
rather than dozens like we do right now
that's important so we can link t cell
levels to levels of infection across
entire populations if preliminary data
holds up about how sturdy our t-cell
reserves are we could space out our
booster shots more than six months apart
with more confidence the expectation for
now is that we're going to need shots on
a yearly basis that's because even if
our t cells are stable the virus is not
the virus doesn't care about any of this
the virus continues to evolve it's this
game of playing hide and seek basically
in the future we could have vaccines
that target multiple strains of the
virus plus companies are working on
nasal spray vaccines which could in
theory help t cells be in the right
place at the right time if we get sick